recall applications are still open if
you consider yourself an artist
march 14th you got time all right as you
may have heard it is a
big day here at vicom cbs we are
launching our new streaming service
paramount
plus it's a platform that features
original programming
including a new season of a wildly
popular show
that's going to make some of us feel
very old mtv's
the real world homecoming new york
brings together
the original seven housemates from the
series
and their first season was 29 years ago
the show is credited with pioneering the
reality tv
genre and our vlad duterte got the
opportunity to reminisce with two of the
original cast members
and to revisit some of the show's
groundbreaking and controversial
moments feeling old vlad good morning
again it's just a state of mind my
friend just a state of mind
uh good morning this is the cast now
and if the picture seems familiar here's
why look at them
in the exact same poses from 29 years
ago
reality tv is everywhere now but at the
time the show was nearly unprecedented
as americans tuned in to see what
happened when as the show's tagline went
people stop being polite and start
getting real
this is the true story true story seven
strangers
in 1992 picked to live in a loft mtv
executives took a gamble on a new type
of show
what when people stop being polite heart
soap opera
part documentary the real world
when i walked through the doors i saw a
new world just walk around
this is where we lived seven young
adults from different backgrounds
moved into a new york city law for three
months with mtv
cameras rolling i don't know what's
going to happen in the next three months
i just
hope i hope everyone gets them heather b
gardner at the time a rapper with a
rising music career join the cast of
what became tv's first
reality show there was no blueprint and
i think
they captured seven 20 year olds
trying to figure it out they're absolute
pigs
my roommates are pigs if you make
something
and you eat just put the dish in the
dishwasher i walk in and half the people
have sunglasses on so i was thinking to
myself okay people don't want to look
each other in the eyes here
kevin powell was one of the seven let's
see what happens it's like this
experiment
i had no idea it's going to become a
phenomenon and change the course of
american tv history who knew
i admire you know the black race i
really do
the real world became a phenomenon
partly because of the uncomfortable
unscripted conversations it captured
between kevin
and his roommates black people are by
far
dominant over white in all schools
first of all you start off with
stereotypes like you know you're
superior in sports and entertainment
actually a lot of people white people
think that's all black people can do you
know what i'm saying i'm not an athlete
man i'm not a singer you know i'm saying
i'm not a rap
i'm a writer have you ever been a black
writer before the conversations about
race and racism which turned into
arguments about race and racism
those things actually happened that's
part of the problem what did you know
about black white thing
it's a reality were they heated yeah
were they passionate yeah were we coming
from where we were at at that time
absolutely
and it's interesting because so many
people of so many races and backgrounds
have said to me
i never heard conversations about race
and racism like that in my life
groundbreaking and controversial the
seasons that followed tackled other
sensitive topics head on
i've made a decision that i'm going to
terminate the pregnancy
like abortion and aids you have to
understand ace
is part of my life three seasons in cast
member pedro zamora became
the first person openly living with hiv
aids to be featured on reality
television
but zamora lost his fight with the
disease he died
just hours after the season finale aired
i thought that was probably one of the
most powerful moments in tv the fact
that he would even
do it because he wanted to bring
awareness to this dreadful disease
i think is probably one of the most
significant moments in in the history of
reality tv period
pedro became a member of all of our
families
now no one in america can say they've
never known someone who's living with
aids
it says something about the importance
of the real world because we literally
capture some things that happen
that that shape this this country for
that i'm very proud of being a part of
the show what is being totally committed
mean to you
after 32 seasons on cable tv the real
world's biggest legacy is what followed
in its weight
the countless other reality shows and a
share everything culture
how did you change everything think
about tick tock think about social media
instagram live facebook live
when i see these things i think of our
season of the real world you know what i
mean just the
people just opening up exposing
themselves sharing their lives
that all started with us it's really
deep but it really did start with us
i can't believe we're in the same place
it still smells the same
it still looks the same okay we are
officially re-roommated
kevin heather and the rest of the
original cast
are poised to finish what they started
almost three decades ago
in january they reunited for a week
at the same new york city loft not many
people
are forced to look at themselves we had
to go back and look
at episodes from 1992. and it wasn't
comfortable
why wasn't it coming mine is 29 years of
your life right now
and just think about the person who you
were back then is how you thought and
what you said
and as an adult now you have to sit and
hear it
not only see yourself but hear it
think about if americans us all of us
were able to go
back in our lives and like you know did
you ever
say or do something you know that you
need to you know process here how have
you evolved from then to now what have
you done
most of us don't get to look back indeed
we don't get to look back it turns out
not all seven cast members were able to
reunite in that new york city law
eric who went on to host a dance show on
mtv had to join
the homecoming virtually the real world
producers mastered the art of a tease
as it turns out 29 years later that's
still the case so you'll just have to
tune in to find out exactly why
wow i love what they said at the end
there but you know going back and
looking at yourself 29 years ago i'm not
sure
any of us really because they all talked
about evolving yeah
a lot of the attitudes in the way they
were 21 22 years old
and some of the things that they were
doing and saying they're not those same
people now yeah
all of them it's a special show in part
because they were saying those things on
television without social media
commenting in real time
and i think i think it probably altered
the freeness of the conversation in a
way that was positive i mean
it really was the real world those first
few seasons and those archetypes that
they invented essentially they continued
the ingenue who comes from the midwest
or from the south
who's never been to the big city you
know even kevin acknowledges that he was
the first angry black man
on television even though the things
that he was talking about back then
have become the norm now the idea is
that he was he was living
it seemed to be very real and honest
conversation i mean very aptly titled
the real world that show was not
scripted right no
not at all yeah like something like some
reality shows now not a beard
at all and they didn't you know the the
idea of what you're talking about
anthony
um the conversations they were having
happened in real time yeah the dishes
you don't ever see people talking about
dishes on a
no survivor at one point that was not
real when i moved to new york 10 years
later my apartment did not look like
they're
i had cockroaches crawling over my legs
and i could feel them now even when i
talk about it so
some things are not real when these days
are over your cockroach days are over
they're not this is new york the
cockroach days are never over i saw
yesterday all right vlad thank you very
much and vlad's conversation with
heather and kevin continues on today's
cbs
sporting podcast and that rat was on my
deck by the way you can watch
mtv's